un parc de maison mobile complètement
anéanti nous sommes à quelques
kilomètres de l'endroit où l'oeil de
Yann a touché terre frappé de plein
fouet la petite ville de port-charlotte
n'a eu aucune chance ces résidents
vivent un cauchemar ce gars
la maison de Jean Murphy et de Marc
Pelletier à muriés mais une partie du
toit c'est quand même envolé ça dépasse
tout ce qu'on a pu avoir vécu auparavant
ça a duré tellement longtemps ça
avançait cinq six mille alors c'est un
supplice très émotionnel OK d'abord ça
vient on fait un coup on balaye on
nettoie on prend un break on recommence
puis quand on voit des situations qu'on
c'est parce que juste
prend on est disconnecté du monde on
sait pas ce qui se passe coupé du monde
ils ne savent même pas que fortnite pas
tellement loin a été dévasté sans
électricité sans au courant ils vont
puiser dans leur piscine pour la
toilette ou la vaisselle je suis pas
dépassé mais presque et je peux pas
concevoir de continuer à vivre de même
pour la prochaine semaine de au moins à
Port Charlotte un semblant de vie
normale a repris aujourd'hui quelques
épiceries ont ouvert leurs portes et des
dizaines de voitures faisaient la file
devant cette station-service une des
rares à voir de l'essence
les résidents en ont pour des mois à
s'en remettre mais on sent leur
solidarité
la maison de mon voisin a pris tout un
coup
je suis venu ramasser un peu avant qu'il
revienne
devant lui il y a cette église détruite
ce n'est pas le Christ tombé que Rodney
a remarqué le plus mais cette croix
encore debout au-dessus d'un drapeau
américain déchiré
cet espoir aujourd'hui c'est ce à quoi
s'accroche les résidents de port
Charlotte on est coréen on est correct
et puis
on va passer au travers comme tout le
monde ici jean-Sébastien Cloutier
Radio-Canada port Charlotte